[موسيقى]
اتهم رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان قياده الدعم السريع
بالطموح الى حكم الى حكم السودان وفي
مداخله مع الجزيره ابدى البرهان استعداد
القوات المسلحه للتفاوض اذا انسحبت قوات
الدعم السريع خارج الخرطوم والتزمت
بمواقعها وفقا لاتفاق ديسمبر كانون الاول
الماضي
اذا تراجعت الدعم السريع وعدت الى مواقعها
واخلص العاصمه نستطيع ان نجلس مع من تبقى
منهم لكي نتفاوض لكن في هذه الظروف
الا اظن ان هنالك خيار اخر غير الحكم
العسكري
الخرطوم عدد كما كانت في ابريل او في
ديسمبر عند توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي العام
الماضي حتما سيكون هنالك وضع مختلف
وقال البرهان للجزيره ان سبب تحرك الدعم
السريع ضد القوات المسلحه هو سعيها الى
توحيد القوات العسكريه مضيفا ان الحسم في
مواقع في موقع حميدتي كنائبا له مازال
مؤجلا
نحن نحافظ على الاطار المؤسسين ونسعى في
تخرج بلدنا باي صيغه من السياق الى بر
الامان ليس لدينا قيود ليس لدينا حدود لكن
لدينا ثوابت وطنيه لدينا امور لا يمكن ان
نترايا عنها يجب ان يكون هنالك جيش وطني
واحد وهو رب الموضوع سبب قيام الدعم
السريع بمهاجمه القوات المسلحه اننا نتحدث
عن ضروره توحيد هذا العسكريه
على الاتفاقا سوء النهائي للامس السياسي
الذي يقصد المرحله الانتقاليه هذا الهجوم
القادم الذي يعتبره قادرا وخيار وتمرد على
الدوله لاننا كنا نثق في وجوههم كانوا
متواجدون معنا في كل مكان في مرافق الخدمه
العسكريه
قال قائد قوات الدعم السريع في السودان
محمد حميتي في مقابله مع الجزيره قال ان
الهدف من العمليات العسكريه في السودان هو
التخلص من قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان
والبدء في عمليه التحول الديمقراطي واضاف
انه دعا الى هدنه انسانيه والى وقف لاطلاق
النار لفتره معينه لكن الطرف الاخر لا
يريد ذلك على حد قوله
لفتره معينه
الدبلوماسيه مثلا
قوات الدعم السريع تلقت اتصالات من كل
الاطراف بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي لتعزيز الهدنه
الشديد
الى تحولا ديمقراطي حقيقي والبرهان هو سبب
المشاكل التي تحول دون تحقيقه
بالمناسبه اختبار يا اخوان الاوروبيين
والغربيين بصفه عامه والناس
بنتكلم عن تحول ديمقراطي حقيقي
وبرهان هو سبب المشاكل